leute was geht ich das ist ein nachtrag
hier und zwar kam ich durch zuschauer
ideen und auf welchen anderes video
gesehen habe auf die idee auch mal so
bayerisch so waffen zu bestellen hat
jetzt nichts gefährliches also ich bin
ja auch der letzte da irgendwie was da
an tun möchte oder so und ich habe dann
halt so ein paar sachen also dass wir
jetzt hier wahrscheinlich so ein kleiner
opener vom kleinen des opening vom video
ich habe dann halt ein paar sachen
bestellt so insgesamt sieben sachen und
hab das dann im nachhinein durch ich hab
mir dabei gar nichts gedacht ich wollte
die sachen halt einfach nur euch mal so
sozusagen vorstellen was man da alles
bestellen kann weil ich auch ganz
interessant fand und hab dann kumpel von
mir gefragt und der meinte jo do musste
aber in deutschland schon aufpassen weil
es ist fast alles was es so an waffen
gibt hier illegal sei es jetzt
schlagringe oder irgendwelche messer
oder so und dann habe ich mir das
angeschaut was sich da konkret gestellt
habe habe das abgeglichen dann ist mir
aufgefallen dass vier dieser sachen die
ich bestellt hat hochgradig illegal sind
in deutschland und habe das dann auch
sofort wieder abgebrochen die bestellung
also ich vermute stark dass wir hier
angekommen weil es kommt ja auch keiner
in die pakete rhein und in anderen
ländern ist es egal
ich kann euch das gern mal kurz zeigen
was ich da bestellt habe und wir wird
man uns in diesem video dann heute
allerdings nur den sachen die ihr egal
sind sonst ich will ja irgendwie keinen
ärger kriegen oder so das war das
dümmste also ich habe angefangen mir
hier so ein schlagring und zubiss
wer halt also eigentlich wusste sie auch
selber dass man das ich darf aber ich
dachte halt so fürs zeigen okay aber
nein habe ich abgebrochen
dann habe ich noch so einen dingen
bestellt das war so ja da kannst du auch
also war wie so ein schlagring nur mit
zuspitzen
das ist auch hochgradig illegal ich will
euch das jetzt hier nicht unbedingt noch
mal zeigen das habe ich auch abgebrochen
und was ich nicht abgebrochen hat was
auch angekommen ist kann ich euch direkt
am anfang mal zeigen da bin ich mir
unsicher ob das jetzt illegal ist weiß
ich nicht genau auf jeden fall moment
zeigt dass euch mal ganz kurz hier genau
hier so ein ding habe ich bestellt so
ein pen life nennt sich das ich hab da
auch schon andere deutsche videos
zugesehen und wenn man sich jetzt zum
beispiel hier diesen artikel anschaut
hat er auch ganz viele bewertungen von
deutschen leuten die den bestellt haben
desktops stift mart und die kinder
bräuchten noch einen schliff pipapo ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt wirklich illegal
ist weil die klinge von den dingen ist
wirklich extrem klein aber im internet
habe ich herausgefunden dass diese
dinger wohl illegal sind deswegen weiß
ich nicht auch wenn ich jetzt mein
kugelschreiber auftreten würde ob da so
ein messer darunter ist ich glaube nicht
ich kann nicht mal zeigen 40
ich kann doch immer zeigen wie dieser
kugelschreiber aussieht den ich gleich
auch direkt entfernen werde weil ich
will ja nicht aufdrehen und da ist
einfach ein messer darunter oder so also
das ist ja dann auch gefährlich
also das ist hier der ganz normale
kugelschreiber den ich bewusst bestellt
habe wirklich jetzt nichts besonderes
kann man auch ganz normal hier auf dem
tisch mit schreiben eben ging das noch
hier kann man sehen also das ding
schreibt halt wirklich und wenn man das
so aufdreht also ich denke bei diesen
kugelschreiber niemann bestellt und
trägst du drehst du das halt auf und da
ist dann so eine kleine klinge drunter
wie sonne finger als ich finde das jetzt
nicht gefährlich oder so muss ich sagen
aber es ist verboten deswegen hier wie
gesagt ich bin mir nicht sicher deswegen
schmeiße ich dir noch weg und das video
drehen wir übrigens auch in tschechien
noch sagt wir tun das furchtbar leid das
video war viel cooler gewesen wenn
deutschland da nicht so so eng ist
vorbei ich finde es auch gut weiß dann
fühlt was ich hier wenigstens sicher
leute kauft euch den blöd sind auf
keinen fall
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit
produkten die legal sind ja mich einiges
bestellt und ich wünsche euch dabei viel
spaß eine sache die ich kurz vielleicht
noch sagen wollte das video ist einfach
nur ein unboxing ich habe gar keinen
bock auf diese leute die jetzt in den
kommentaren rummel striktes vorbild
bürgerblock ich bin glaube ich der
liebste mensch der welt und ich würde
niemals irgendwie was man zu solchen
sachen machen ich packen muss sein
auskommen scheiß auf wir fangen kann
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja leute ich hab
natürlich euch geht es gut ich habe
jetzt mal den kommentaren gelesen wir
nicht so auf dem tisch haue ist das
schlecht für die zuschauer wenn ihnen
danach noch kopfhörer zu haben das nicht
so gut
leute wir befinden uns hier wieder in
der neuen location heute gibt es ein
video in dem wir thematisieren ich habe
vor einiger zeit mal den tipp bekommen
oder die zuschauer fragen bekommen ob
ich meine waffen bei fisch bestellen
kann also alles mögliche sage ich jetzt
eine pistole oder irgendwie so messer
oder so und ich dachte mir das passt auf
jeden fall richtig gut auf meinen kanal
das machen wir heute
ich habe einiges bestellt hat extrem
lange gedauert bis das an
bis leider ich weiß nicht woran es liegt
zurzeit das ist bei vielen webseiten
sind die probleme da so deswegen würde
ich sagen will aber gar nicht lange und
checken direkt mal das erste produkt ab
so erfolgt wahrscheinlich gerade warum
ihren amazon paket liegt das erkläre ich
euch gleich noch das habe ich also das
habe ich nicht bestellt dieses produkt
juli übrigens weise es kam einfach an
gestern ich dachte so hey was ist das da
sind einfach so tücher drin obwohl und
ich habe es nie verstellt hat ihr das
auch schon mal leute ist kann sein ich
habe so viel bei amazon bestellt letzter
zeit ich habe mir schon gedacht man kann
vielleicht bald wieder raus machen
werden noch mehr sachen kommt auf jeden
fall ist dass sie das erste produkt was
ich bestellt habe es ist sozusagen also
es liegt schon brutal auf meine mutter
hat auch immer sohn am schlüsselanhänger
hat sie immer so eine spitze weiß wo man
so feinde damit wie bei call of duty
kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten
produkt wir haben hier ein outdoor
survival also wirklich sonst gerät zwei
euro 76 hat das gekostet
hier gibt es eine rote bewertung zu
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an 4,3 sterne
super sehr schöner lieferungen alles
besten live schreibt das messer ist für
diesen preis von guter qualität es
schneidet auf papier ohne probleme
cristian schreibt schönes kleines
handliches messer mit gürtelclip gut zu
verstauen auch in der hosentasche gut
verarbeitet ist es normal dass man
besser in der hosentasche mit führt so
hätte ich eigentlich
na ja das wird sich jetzt ändern so dann
wollen wir doch mal gucken so ich hätte
mir das jetzt eigentlich größer
vorgestellt ist da auf diesen bildern
größer aus
ok ok ich muss jetzt gerade grübeln wie
das ausgeht aber es ist ganz einfach du
musst einfach auf geschaffen
es ist schon auch gefährlich ist schon
krass
ich weiß nicht also ich muss sagen ich
finde es auf jeden fall sehr interessant
was man alles so easy im internet
bestellen kann schon ein bisschen
bedrückend also finde ich wobei das hier
jetzt auch ist halt ein taschenmesser
taschenmesser führt man anscheinend laut
junis papa schon immer mit deswegen
würde ich sagen wir machen uns jetzt an
die kohlen produkte und checken mal
diese kleine pistole ab mini pistole die
ich da ja für neun euro geschossen habe
let's go okay leute jetzt bin ich
wirklich gespannt wir haben hier eine
mini pistole für neun euro
also ich immer gespannt ich glaube da
müssten auch so coolen bei sein ich
denke mal das ist so ähnlich wie eine
wii der software halten
ich muss sagen ich habe früher somit
einen freund mit zwölf jahren habe ich
mal so softer schlachten gemacht
insofern häusern mit saison droht ein
bisschen gestört schon macht es nicht
nach auf jeden fall übernimmt über 0,5
joule steht hierbei das können schon
also wenn ich dir damit auf den armen
schieße das tut schon weh christen dorf
lag ja klar wenn du zweifel hast wenn
damit hellte grün drin sind also das ist
schon nicht ohne da muss man aufpassen
taxi oder extra noch einmal
[Musik]
ich habe sogar extra noch auf amazon
google dazu gestellt weil ich dachte
hier werden keine bei jetzt habe ich
eben noch mal hier rein gedruckt und
hier unten sind einfach welche mit
drücken das ist ein bisschen blöd nur
wenn man jetzt schon gekauft haben zeige
ich euch die natürlich auch hier wird
jetzt hier schön warum geknallt wenn er
nicht richtig hinter der kamera ist
gibt's erstmal die kugel okay leute also
das hier ist das dingen auch eigentlich
relativ schwer muss ich sagen also für
neun euro finde ich kann man da auf
keinen fall meckern
ich habe keinen plan was das für eine
marke ist glaube gar keine keine abend
könnte ich da jetzt auch überhaupt nicht
aus wenn ihr euch da aus kann schreibt
gerne in die kommentare
ich würde sagen wir laden die jetzt wahr
und schießen dann mal irgendwo drauf
oder so dann steckt man die kugeln hier
einfach ins magazin
wir nehmen jetzt eine marc coma das
sieht so schön aus hier ich lasse das
einfach mal zu 6 mm
übrigens ist das okay 1 2346 kugeln
passt und rein dann ist das magazin auch
schon voll um wein damit hat eine sehr
gute idee ich habe hier mal so ein
bürger brötchen genommen weil ich sehr
gerne selber bürger mache und ich
schieße jetzt mal drauf mal gucken ob
das durchgeht okay bin ich mal gespannt
summe ran
also das war wirklich ein bisschen mehr
ich ziehe jetzt einfach mal ab da gegen
die wand
[Musik]
haye schon kaputt oder was was das denn
euro
sorry
eine davon booms hinter jetzt nicht so
krass aber ist hanna 399 euro gekostet
was will man da erwarten also hier was
ich wirklich gar nichts ausgelöst ich
bezweifle auch dass sie über 0,5 joule
hat also ich denke wenn ich mich abmelde
da werde ich keinen fleck bekommt
probieren wir allerdings nicht aus falls
das jetzt jemand vielleicht denke ich
mache das nicht nein kommt nervt nicht
ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal die gelben
kugeln reingemacht amazon und das
brötchen hier aufgestellt wir checken
jetzt mal auf die vielleicht besser sind
immer wenn ich jetzt treffe
sorry ich tat gab es leute die ist ihnen
schon blöd eine sache habe ich nur der
fand ich so wirklich brutal aus und zwar
haben seit wann sind die preise
bayerisch eigentlich so ein eur 66 51
sage ja noch nie gesehen
hier habe ich bestellt ein ohren durch
bohrer
bitte beachten sie die beschreibung für
einen sicheren betrieb schmerzloser usa
ein rekord stecher habe ich bestell
natürlich es war eine waffe der tisch
auf jeden fall schon wieder sehr gut aus
sagt achim aal hier sind sogar zwei bei
also ich kann mir heute vorstellen dass
das nicht so hygienisch ist wenn man
sich jemand damit nicht leute bei 10.000
likes nein leute bei 100000 likes ich
mache nur noch mit videobeweis
ich glaube da ist noch die rektorin mit
meinem mann
hattest du nicht mal ein ohrring sommer
a ha jung ich bin ja so blöd in china
ist das bestimmt gang und gäbe dass man
das so selfmade zu hause macht ne kommen
jetzt noch mal gerade nicht so ganz
geklappt du hast jetzt stellt euch euer
ohrläppchen dazwischen vor und dann
drückst du das einfach zack und dann ist
der ohren gestochen ja das war wirklich
ein sehr interessantes video für mich es
hat spaß gemacht kauft euch am besten
gar nichts davon würde ich euch
empfehlen weil das ist alles das das
braucht man nicht so zeugs ich habe es
jetzt hier für das unboxing gemacht ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen abonniert auf
jeden fall alle fleißigen kanal wir
sehen uns hier am sonntag wieder gibt es
ein neues video und wirklich geiles
video und dank fürs zuschauen checkt
auch gerne einen zweiten kanal abkommen
täglich jacksons haut rein
[Musik]